hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et tu tapes le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger et quartier qu'on
regarde il est 16 heures lorsque mathieu
alias khadr comme il veut désormais
qu'on l'appelle arrive devant les locaux
de des huîtres à la baisse marboula la
baisse salut c'est mathieu comptes imap
et ans par mon salut c'est le cas d'air
froid je vois tu renvoies est arrivé à
froid fini le petit chroniqueur timide
depuis sa victoire face à rohff la star
des all entend bien se faire respecter
- ça tient tête même s'il leur a fallu
un petit temps d'adaptation les
collègues de khadr ont su l'accepter tel
qu'il est avec ses défauts et surtout
ses qualités
si on a peur dans le regard des gens
j'ai mis le rap français à genoux martin
des 8,6 mater si nassimah biac malgré sa
nouvelle image khadr est à cheval sur
cette heure vestimentaire salamalecs qui
ne veut rien laisser au hasard
cinq points c'est de la merde ça pour
but de montrer pourquoi une carte house
quoi tu crois j'ai porté sound lâchera
n'a là dedans ça c'est si la farine
s'asseoit avec ça tu seras le mot kader
charlot 18h nous sommes à une heure du
show et pour évacuer la pression du
direct qui adhèrent m s'isoler dans sa
loge am3 dreux de paix ouais tu vois tes
zik se détend à l'agachon temps de faire
un petit périscope okah est rennes avec
mon pote auriez attendait mais c'est la
loge de cyril ça non c'est une qu'elle
sert il est ce que c'est une gaine mon
frère c'est juste fou d'un monstre et
encore ils rêvent de la place comme la
coupe
il est 21h30 l'émission vient de se
terminer et après deux heures de show
kader va enfin s'accorder un repos bien
mérité alors kader quoi de prévu ce soir
match de boxe thaï ou concert de la
fouine annonce ce soir ses meilleurs
pâtissiers sur m6 et en plus il spécial
people j'adore pour nokia un fraisier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis ce reportage le jeune homme
racketter au début du sujet c'est lui en
couple avec thierry moreau avec qui il
élève deux magnifiques fox-terrier quant
à la styliste de kader elle a été nommé
pdg de la chaîne numéro 23
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]